continúo avanzando en chile- el proceso
de la convención constitucional y en las
últimas horas en el pleno se aprobó una
de las normas que ha generado quizás más
polémica se tiene que ver con que el
estado garantizará el derecho de los
pueblos y naciones indígenas respecto de
sus tierras los territorios y también
los recursos naturales que están
contenidos en las mismas esta norma fue
aprobada en el pleno por 106 votos a
favor 37 en contra y 10 abstenciones y
ha generado polémica porque entre otras
cosas considera un mecanismo de
restitución de los territorios que
requiere entre otras cosas de buscar un
precio justo como se ha definido ante la
necesidad de eventuales expropiaciones y
es allí en donde los intereses
económicos han chocado también con los
ideales de algunos convencionales en
este caso la mayoría de quienes componen
el pleno de la convención constitucional
en chile- en la región de la araucanía
en gran parte de la zona del conflicto
indígena en chile se concentra quizás el
número más grande de actividad forestal
de papeleras y de allí entonces que haya
riesgos para al menos este sector o
inquietud respecto de lo que podría
significar aplicación de esta norma un
tema adicional tiene que ver con la
amplia actividad agrícola en estas zonas
que es podría ser justamente uno de los
temas que podría de una otra manera en
trabar las negociaciones a futuro al
menos así lo dicen los convencionales
que se han opuesto a esta iniciativa
quienes han votado a favor que en este
caso hay que recordar fueron más de un
centenar han señalado que con esto se da
un importante gesto de reparación y de
restitución también para los pueblos
originarios en chile